welcome to you cherry from what I hear
that any mention of the Tiananmen Square
massacre is banned on Chinese social
media so what happens when someone tries
to search this on Chinese social media
yes so as you said any discussion of the
incident it's censored on Chinese social
media and actually there's a list of
keywords that are deemed sensitive by
the Chinese government so this morning I
did a try to search for keywords on
Weibo and I typed in 8 9 6 4 which is a
year and the date where the incident
happened
and on Weibo it shows that no results
can be found and so other keywords such
as Tiananmen incident or Tiananmen
crackdown also have the same results and
Weibo the Chinese equivalent of Twitter
is actually one of the most important
platform in China and such an important
incident is not mentioned on the
platform really shows that censorship in
China is very powerful and do people
find ways to get around the censorship
is it possible yeah Chinese social media
uses they are trying to be really
creative in their post and so there's an
archive done by a Hong Kong Research
Institute and they kept more than a
thousand Weibo posts before they were
taken down here it shows all these
photos and sensitive was that are
censored on Weibo and in one of the most
iconic picture where we all know a
Chinese user put rubber ducks in sec of
the tank and to try to get over the
censorship and of course when this photo
was widely shared it costs sensitive
again it became sensitive content and so
it really shows this cat-and-mouse game
between Chinese social media users and
the censor Duke Chinese people talk
about the Tiananmen Square massacre on
foreign social media platforms so even
though Facebook and Twitter they are
banned inside China many Chinese social
media uses they try to get around it
they use VPN to get access to these
foreign platforms and actually Twitter
is one of the most important platform
for political discussions for Chinese
users
then just a few days ago many Twitter
users complained that there is a large
amount of Chinese accounts that get
suspend Twitter later apologized and
that they said this is just of one of
the routine checkup but many Chinese
people don't buy the story and regarding
the sensitive time and the kind of
concept were suspend and also actually
just last month Wikipedia was also taken
down in China so like there are many
Chinese social media users they are
fearing that even foreign platforms if
they cannot even find the information of
the incident on foreign platforms okay
cherry Chan a DDR B social media editor
thank you very much for that information
on the 30th anniversary of the Tiananmen
Square massacre